Hello, class. This
lecture will focus on
the pharmacology of
multiple sclerosis.
And this is a
neurological disease of
demyelination where the
patient will experience
neuronal loss and
ultimately disability.
With this disease,
as patients progress,
there will be
episodes where
patients can have
worsening of symptoms.
One of the main ones
is optic neuritis,
and this is going
to be managed with
glucocorticoids or
corticosteroids is
another name for them.
So I will review the
mechanism of
glucocorticoids in this
lecture and some of
the adverse effects.
Understand that with
MS, there's going
to be an increase
in pathological
lymphocytes and
macrophages, and they are
going to degrade myelin
sheath. And myelin
is supposed to protect
the neurons. So
without it, ultimately
what will happen
is that the neurons
are going to die.
So many of the
treatments are going
to be immunotherapies.
They're
going to work to
somehow decrease these
T lymphocytes and
B lymphocytes.
There'll be some
of them that bind
to specific
targets, and some of
these drugs you
will revisit again
when you do cancer
chemotherapy.
So I will go
through the adverse
effects. And one
thing to note
with adverse
effects as a group,
these drugs do
cause some level of
immunosuppression.
So we need to be
mindful of patients
now getting infections.
So if the patient
presents with fever,
malaise, sore throat,
it's a good idea to
check the complete
blood count. And with
many of these drugs, you
will have to do this
before starting the
treatment and throughout
therapy. Same thing,
You need to order a
CMP to look at the
patient's liver panel or
their kidney function.
The other thing
is that MS does
present with
other symptoms.
So they may
experience depression.
They may have trouble
with incontinence.
They may have
erectile dysfunction.
So it's not just going
to be the immunotherapy.
we will be using
other drugs to manage
these symptoms and I
will go through some
of the most common
ones in the lecture.
So MS is relapsing or
progressive okay and
probably the most
common is the relapsing
remitting form of MS
where the patient has
the disorder but has
periods of remission
and that is really the
goal of therapy is to
keep the patient in
remission as much as
possible. You want to
slow the progression of
the disease. So with
demyelination, we're
going to have an
increase of B and T cells
that are pathological.
This is mediated by
T helper cell 1 and
17. T helper cell 2,
which is the target
of one of the drugs I
will discuss, glatiromir,
actually enhances
Th2, which can actually
be a therapeutic
because it has an anti
-inflammatory property.
MS tends to happen more
in females versus males.
You are diagnosed
younger, meaning by the
time somebody is
between 20 and 30 years
old, they will be
diagnosed. It's very
rare to see somebody
in their 60s present
for the first time
with symptoms of MS.
Genetics can play a
role. Smoking, even
though we think about
the lungs and the heart
and atherosclerosis,
remember smoking
does introduce ROSs,
which has been implicated
to be part of the
pathogenesis of MS.
And we do have a drug
that actually works
against ROS production.
And then Epstein
-Barr has been shown to
perhaps be implicated
in MS because they
see that in many
patients with MS, they
have the presence of
antibodies of Epstein
-Barr in their blood.
And remember, when
you are showing
antibodies, that means
either you got the vaccine,
which we don't have
one for Epstein
-Barr, or you've been
exposed to the virus.
And then lastly,
vitamin D. Even though
vitamin D initially,
and it still is, needed
to absorb your calcium
for bone health,
there's been a lot of
disorders that have
been attributed to
maybe having low
vitamin D levels, whether
it be neurological
diseases, even
Parkinson's, Alzheimer's,
MS, and even some
cancers. So this
is why I have this
in question mark.
So here is what we
need to understand. We
have these reactive or
pathological T cells
that are outside the
CNS, and they're going
to cross the blood
-brain barrier inside.
And what will happen
is you're going to get
an increase of cytokines,
and that's going
to turn on the B
-cells, which are going
to be responsible for
creating autoantibodies
to the myelin, or
we're going to have
an increase in
cytotoxic T-cells, which
increase granzymes, and
granzymes are responsible
for enhancing apoptosis
or cell death.
So, as I mentioned,
many of the
therapies are
going to be against
the B-cells or
the T cells.
And we do have
a drug that
binds to the
receptor here.
And I will speak about
it a little bit later.
It's called
natalizumab. And this
drug, by binding
here, prevents the
entry of the T
cells into the CNS.
So for acute management
of MS symptoms, we
use glucocorticoids.
Now glucocorticoids,
as I mentioned, we
need to be mindful that
there are certain
adverse effects. Number
one, you never discontinue
a glucocorticoid
flat. You need to taper
off. Even if you're
going from an IV
form to maybe an oral
prednisone or even later
to an inhaled form, you
need to have a few
days where the patient
is getting a lowering
of the dose. That's
because leukocorticoids
can have an effect
on hypothalamic pituitary
axis suppression.
This is almost
like when you
remove the drug,
the body doesn't
know what to do
at that moment.
do we make more
corticosteroid naturally
or we don't and what
ends up happening in
that time period the
patient can actually
get a reactivation of
symptoms so you want
to taper these
medications and IV
methylprednisolone is
actually the first medication
that we will give
for optic neuritis
Optic neuritis
in the MS patient
results from an
autoimmune damage to the
myelin of the optic
nerve. The patient
will present
with eye pain and
they're going to have
difficulty seeing.
The rest of these
drugs are going to
be mainly for the
relapsing remitting
component. And as I
mentioned, this is
when the patient
has the disorder but
is able to be
maintained in remission
and is able to do
all their functions.
Ultimately, we're
slowing the disease
progression with
these medications.
The issue is when
the patient goes into
secondary progressive.
That is now when
they're getting a
worsening of their
disease, almost like
they're turning the
corner. And that's
when we will give
mitoxantrone. And this
is an anti-neoplastic.
So you will study this
again later when you
do chemotherapy. and
then cladribine is
another one and this
one can be used for
the relapsing remitting
by the way the
cladribine so glucocorticoids
I want to stay
say that as a mechanism
they're stopping
everything from the
beginning so for example
when we're talking
about prostaglandins
one way that that can
be manage is by giving
a cyclooxygenase
blocker, like an NSAID,
whether it be Advil
or Motrin, which
is ibuprofen. And by
blocking COX, you're
not going to make
prostaglandin E2.
And this is what's
responsible for
giving you the pain
and inflammation
you feel when, say,
you pull a muscle.
Aspirin, in addition,
targets thromboxane,
and thromboxane is
responsible for platelet
aggregation. We give
lots of aspirin, like
81 milligrams every
day, to those patients
that have had a cardiac
issue. So if they've
had an MI or a ******
in the past, they
usually will be put on
81 milligrams a day,
not for the anti
-inflammatory, but for the
fact that this is going
to block platelets.
On the side here,
which I talk
about the lung
pathway, Anyway,
lipooxygenase is blocked
by ziluton, and the
leukotriene D4 receptor
is blocked by the
leukast drugs, like
montalukast, pranlukast.
These will be drugs
that you would use, for
example, if you have
somebody with asthma,
maybe COPD, maybe
allergic-induced asthma.
But as I said, we
have specific drugs
on each side of the
tree. but the one
that blocks everything
from the starting
point is going to
be glucocorticoids.
These drugs will
stimulate lipocortin and
by doing that they
inhibit phospholipase A2.
So once that happens
and you don't have
arachnodonic acid,
you can't make either
glucotrienes or
prostaglandins. So this
is why glucocorticoids
can be used for
say patients that are
having an exacerbation
of asthma, and
they're presenting to
the ED, and they
need to be given IV
methylprednisolone,
or maybe somebody who
perhaps has inflammatory
bowel disease,
okay, may need a
glucocorticoid because
that patient is getting
a lot of symptoms
related to
inflammation. Okay, so
these drugs are widely
used. They should be
used sparingly, but
they are used for
many different
inflammatory conditions.
How they work is through
a nuclear receptor
mechanism where
you're going to affect
nuclear transcription
or gene transcription.
So right now
we see that the
drug is binding
to its binding
globulin and it
enters the cell.
Receptors are
maintained stable by
heat shock proteins.
Once the drug
binds to the receptor,
these dissociate,
and now your
receptor drug or
receptor ligand
complex is unstable.
This allows now
for dimerization to
happen, which continues
in the nucleus.
And this happens on
response elements.
So this is the
glucocorticoid
response element.
Thyroid hormone,
estrogen hormone,
progesterone,
the fat-soluble
vitamins like
D, E, K, and A,
they're all going to
have their specific
response element.
So you'll see
for thyroid, this will
be thyroid response
element. And
you're going to get
the activation of
gene transcription.
Messenger RNA is
going to now create
protein, and you're
going to get a response.
So glucocorticoids,
as I mentioned, should
be used sparingly
because over time, and
this is especially
true in those pediatric
patients who have
gotten various courses
of glucocorticoid for
asthma, there tends
to be a decrease in
growth hormone. That's
why we see that kids
that are given too
much glucocorticoids
early in their life
tend not to grow as
much as their peers.
In addition, this
is going to have an
effect on metabolism.
You're going to get an
increase in
gluconeogenesis, which means
the liver is making
more glucose. That
can complicate somebody
that has diabetes.
You're also going to
get some issue where
the patient can't
affect, their adipose
tissue is affected.
So they're going to
present with that
cushionoid effect where
they're going to be
somewhat round in their
belly. They're going
to have the moon face.
And incidentally,
when we're talking
about the skin,
especially in
the extremities,
they lose muscle.
So it's going to be
almost like they're
skinny, so to speak, in
their extremities, but
they're going to have
like a belly. And
that has to do with the
fact that you're getting
redistribution of
the fat. It also can
increase free fatty
acid production, so you
could get an increase
in your lipid panel.
The other thing
is that since
this drug can
affect aldosterone,
aldosterone being
increased can
increase salt and
water retention.
And that can
lead to edema or
it can lead to
hypertension.
And then lastly, it's
the bone. This is
the big problem and
why a lot of doctors
don't like to get
repeated injections
of glucocorticoids
when you're in pain.
With the bone,
these drugs
increase osteoclasts.
And remember, osteoclasts
can break down bone.
The other thing is
that they have a
negative impact on
vitamin D. So if you're
excreting vitamin D
or you can't absorb
vitamin D, therefore
you cannot absorb
calcium. So this is
another mechanism by how
these drugs can
negatively affect bone.
So here we are with
allentuzumab. And
this is an interesting
medication because
it's going to break
down T and B cells.
It's going to
bind, of course,
to CD52.
So as you can see
here, number one, we're
going to have
complement dependent
cytotoxicity. What does
that mean? Well, you're
going to see that the
antibody will bind to
the antigen and then
you're going to get
an increase, once
they bind together and
they activate, you're
going to get an
increase of membrane
attack complex and that
is going to lead to
cell lysis. So that's
one mechanism. The
other one is due to this
antibody dependent cell
mediated cytotoxicity.
This is where now
the drug comes in
and it coats the target
with these antibodies
and then following
that you're going
to get the breakdown
of CD52 of the T and
the B cells. Okay,
so basically this has
to do now with coding
of the drug to the
effector cells. And
then lastly would be the
fact that you're going
to get apoptosis.
Okay, and remember,
apoptosis is programmed
cell death. You're going
to have an increase
in caspases in this
mechanism. And ultimately,
again, you're going
to get cell death.
Some of the issues here
is that, number one,
it is advised
that anybody
considering pregnancy
does use some
form of
contraception, okay?
The other thing is,
as mentioned, you're
going to get a depletion
of lymphocytes,
which again makes
the patient at a
greater risk of
developing an infection.
The antibodies here,
they're antibodies
that can be formed
and can cause
something called an
autoimmune response.
One place this
could happen is
in the thyroid,
and you will
get a resulting
thyroiditis.
So if the patient
presents with symptoms
of hypothyroidism,
whether they're
cold all the time,
losing their hair,
they're having
fatigue, weight gain,
constipation, a decrease
in cardiac effects,
you would try to look at
the patient's
thyroid panel.
And then the other
thing is that patients
can experience an
autoimmune thrombocytopenia.
So again, it's very
advisable, as mentioned
in the first slide,
that you do the CBC
because you can see the
platelets on the CBC.
So that will be
important to monitor.
Infusion reactions
are going to happen
with many of these
drugs. And this
is important because
for the most part,
they can be annoying
to the patient.
However,
there's ways that we
can manage that. We
can give pretreatment
with an antihistamine.
That's usually the main
one that we would do.
Monitor the
patient afterwards.
Okay, so we'll go
over this again.
As mentioned,
alimtuzumab can be
used for chronic
lymphocytic leukemia
and T-cell lymphoma.
Why?
Because ultimately
what you would want to
achieve in that
situation is cell lysis.
Just a little bit about
monoclonal antibodies.
You're going to see
many of them, whether
it be here and as you
go through the year
when you do cancer
chemotherapy these are
being you know bought
to market very often
okay because that's
pretty much the new wave
of cancer chemotherapy
because you're
targeting a specific
target instead of giving
a drug that's going
to affect all of the
cells in your body and
cause adverse effects
so when you see a umab
that means that the
monoclonal is made of
only human construct.
A momab is
mouse or murine.
A gzimab is chimeric
which means it's a
mixture of both
mouse and human. And
then a zoomab is
humanized. That means
there is some degree
of mouse in the
construct but not as
much as compared to
chimeric. So what
does this mean to you?
The idea here is
that some people
can get an immune
response if the
construct is obtained
from the animal.
So that would mean
that they may have
more effects. So as
much as possible,
we try to make these
constructs human.
But again, it's not
always a possibility.
So it's important
that if you're giving
something that has an
an animal construct,
the patient can feel
that antigenic effect
and that can elicit
an immune response
and that can change
the course of therapy.
So it would just be
important for you
to note when this
medication is infused
and to watch them
for adverse effects.
So dimethylfumarate
is considered to
be a prodrug that
is activated to a
metabolite known as
monomethylfumarate.
And that now will
activate NRF2.
And NRF2 is now going
to arrive in the
nucleus, kind of like
what we saw a few minutes
ago with glucocorticoids.
And it's going
to find an antioxidant
response element.
And you're going to
get dimerization.
And with this
dimerization, you're going
to get the production
of antioxidants.
And the one that is
mostly the one that
we want to achieve
is glutathione. And
glutathione is made
by our liver. We do
make, I don't recall
off the top of my head
how many millimoles
we make in a day,
but that is our own
natural protectant.
This will increase its
production because,
as mentioned, there
is a component of MS
pathology that might
be due to activation
of ROSs. The other
thing it can do is it
does have some anti
-inflammatory effects.
Some of these
mediators are anti
-inflammatory. And that
does help prevent the
activation of those
toxic lymphocytes.
Some of the adverse
effects that we
will go through here
is that patients
can experience
GI upset, okay,
flushing, and something
called a progressive
multifocal
leukoencephalopathy or a PML.
This is interesting.
It tends to happen
in patients that are
immunosuppressed like
an HIV patient, and
this is due to the
fact that there's an
activation of a JC
virus in the white
matter of the brain. It's
called John Cunningham
virus. And it
seems to be that we
all have some level of
that in the brain, but
it becomes activated
when you are
immunosuppressed. Now, if
you put one of these
drugs on board, that
can activate this
virus. And what will
happen is the patient
will present with
a loss of coordination,
memory, weakness.
So that would be
critical, that you
stop the medication
and that you evaluate
the patient if
this should happen.
Elevated liver enzymes,
because again, the
site of action here is
somewhat in the liver,
especially when we
talk about glutathione
and where it comes
from, where it's made.
And then an increase
in infection risk.
The next one is
known as a modulator,
and we call it
fingolomod. It's
a modulator of
immune response.
This is an interesting
medication. It's
kind of exciting.
This is a drug that
will bind to this
sphingosine 1
-phosphate 1 receptor.
And by doing that,
as you can see,
it starts to
capture lymphocytes.
and it takes lymphocytes
in, and it sequesters
lymphocytes. Sequesters
means that it
holds it in one place
until the lysosomes now
are ready to absorb
them and break them
down. Okay, so this is
the way it reduces the
toxic lymphocytes, by
breaking them down.
Very interesting
medication. it does
have adverse effects.
There can be some
headaches, some
activation of
infections like
everything else, and then
PML, especially if
we were dealing with
somebody who was
immunosuppressed.
It can cause basal
cell carcinoma.
They're not sure why
this is happening. They
tend to think that
it's when you give
this with something
like natalizumab.
Again, if the patient,
you know, has moles
and they start to
see that something is
off, that the mole
is changing, that's
something that they
need to have looked at.
The other thing is
you need to test your
varicella antibodies.
So varicella is the
virus of the chicken
pox and the shingles.
If this is activated
in say patients that
are older, you may
get a patient that
gets shingles. So if
you look at the antibody
and you feel that
they're not in the
right range, what the
recommendation is,
get them the shot, the
shingrix, okay, that's
the ****** zoster
virus drug vaccine.
Give them the vaccine
and then they can
start the drug
probably, you know,
maybe a month later.
Okay. But we want to
make sure that they're
not going to get
an activation of
the shingles. Okay.
The other thing
is we need to
evaluate at
the first dose.
And if you give the
drug again, we want to
do an EKG because
there's been episodes of
patients having
bradycardia when taking
fingolimod. And bradycardia
means that the patient
is having a lowering
of their heart rate.
Usually it's below
60 beats per minute.
Why is this happening?
Is that there's these
sphingosine receptors
in the AV and SA
node of the heart.
The SA node is the
pacemaker. The AV node
is one of those nodes.
It's the atrial
ventricular node. It's
between the atria
and the ventricles,
and that's going to
slow down the rate.
So if we had a problem
with our AV node,
we can have a heart
rate of like 400,
okay? In this case
there may be a decrease
in AV node suppression
and that can lead
to the bradycardia.
You'll understand more
when we do cardiac
next fall. But the
thing to understand
is when the drug binds
to the sphingosine
receptors in the heart
there's going to be an
increase in potassium
flow inside and that
can lead to a decrease
in heart rate. So this
would be especially
important if say
the patient wasn't
on an AV node suppressing
like a beta blocker
or a calcium channel
blocker. You may
need to change the
dose of the cardiac
medication or maybe even
find another medication
for the MS. But
either way, you need
to make sure that
the patient is having
regular EKGs to look
at the heart rate and
looking at the overall
rhythm of the heart.
Glatiramir, this is
the one that I had
mentioned, was responsible
for increasing TH2.
And TH2 tends to be
an anti-inflammatory
cytokine. So
that is actually
protective to
patients that have MS.
So a little bit
about this medication
is that it is given
subcutaneously.
It also will increase
something called brain
-derived neurotropic
factor, BDNF. And this
one actually helps the
nerve cells survive.
So in essence, it's
increasing neurons.
The more neurons
you produce, so to
speak, from this
factor, the more
neuroprotection. Because
we have more neurons
that are going to
have myelin. So that
is very protective
in somebody with MS.
A couple of things
that we have to be
mindful of is the
injection site reaction.
And so again, why do
infusion reactions occur?
Seems to be due to
the fact that when
you infuse these
medications,
there's going to be
an increase in IgE.
And IgE is going
to be related to an
increase of histamine.
So giving an
antihistamine like
diphenhydramine is very
important to help
manage these reactions.
The infusion reactions
can also be due
to an increase in
cytokines. Some physicians
may say, well, I
want to give a small
dose of a glucocorticoid.
That may not
be incorrect, but
again, you want to be
mindful of the dose
of glucocorticoid.
Post-injection, patients
can feel flushing,
dyspnea or shortness
of breath, and some
palpitations. This
occurs only once,
but it's a good idea
that the patient
is monitored in
that period of time
because they may get
some level of panic.
They may be worried
about the racing
heart. So they
should be advised to
somewhat be seated and
wait a while before
going on with the
rest of their day.
The other thing
is that with any
subcutaneous injection,
whether it be this or
when I lecture on
insulin next year,
subcutaneous injections
can can lead to
something called
lipoatrophy this is where
there's a loss of
fat at the injection
site it tends to be
due to an autoimmune
response and basically
if you see what
happens it's almost
like an indentation if
you look it up on
google you'll see that
the place where they
inject it it's kind
of flat and then
the rest of the the
arm so to speak is
the same. It's fatter.
One thing to do in
order to prevent this
from happening is to
rotate the injection
site. And we say
that to patients
that are using insulin.
Don't inject in
the same site. If
you inject in the arm
today, maybe inject
in the leg tomorrow
or the other arm the
next day. This way
you stop this idea
of this loss of fat.
Interferon. Very
important because
interferon will see
it again next year
when we talk about
hepatitis B and C.
This is a cytokine.
For MS, ultimately
what we're going to
do is inhibit T-cell
activation and the
cross through the
blood-brain barrier.
It works via the
Janus kinase and
signal transduction
and activation of
transcription pathway.
So the drug binds,
cytoplasm, you're going
to get an increase
in signal transduction
and activation of
transcription because
kinases phosphorylate.
This phosphorylation
reaction continues
now into the nucleus
where, again, we're
finding a response
element. So you're
getting that dimerization
reaction happening
again. But
it's due to the
phosphorylations made
possible by Janus kinase.
With respect to
treating or managing
hepatitis B and C,
that's going to elicit
antiviral immunity.
For the specific
one that is for MS,
B1A, that is going
to do this action.
Stop T-cells from
being activated and
stop the cross over.
This medication
is effective, but
it can cause flu
-like symptoms.
So the patient
is going to have
several days of
feeling weak.
They're going to
feel tired. They may
have a fever. They may
have a sore throat.
They're going to have
some depression. And
we see this commonly
in patients that
are using this for all
of these disorders.
It seems to be that
there is a decrease
in neurotransmitter
production
with interferon.
And for depression,
that's going to be
mostly serotonin.
When we talk about
injection reactions,
again, we might
need to give an
antihistamine if
the patient is
sensitive to these
infusion reactions.
And then lastly, anemia.
It seems to be that
interferons can
suppress something known
as erythropoiesis.
Erythro applies to the red
blood cells. So if
you're not making blood
cells, then the patient
is going to be more
prone to being anemic
okay so again going
back to the lab test
you want to order a CBC
is always on the
list so now we have
natalizumab okay I call
it we used to call it
natalie okay just as a
way for us to remember
but anyway this drug
binds to a receptor as
you can see here this
is called alpha 4 B1,
okay? And this
is going to stop,
okay, or inhibit adhesion
to this specific
molecule,
VCAM. VCAM stands
for vascular cell
adhesion molecule 1.
So if this is going
to be stopped. You're
not going to get
adhesion. No adhesion,
no crossover. And
as I mentioned,
once you cross over,
that's when it starts
to interact with
the neurons and cause
the myelination.
So this is preventing
the crossover, so
to speak. Okay. Very
exciting mechanism of
action, okay?
But again, the
infusion reactions,
the increase in
PML, again, back
to the JC virus,
hepatotoxicity, so
we got to do our
liver function
tests with this one,
and there's an
increase in infection
risk, okay? I can't
say it enough.
And natalizumab
can also be used
for Crohn's disease.
Crohn's disease
is another
inflammatory disorder.
Usually the main
treatment is
the TNF-alpha drugs,
which are also
monoclonals,
like infliximab,
adeolimumab.
Those will be
discussed in later
days, but this one
can sometimes be
used if the patient
is not responding
well to those TNF
-alpha inhibitors.
So CD20,
very important. When
I think of CD20, the
first thing I think of
is the B cells, okay?
And that's what these
drugs are doing.
They're going to be
given as an IV infusion.
They're going to
deplete CD20 in both
the B and also the
T cells. And with
these drugs, it's
been observed that
they can also
stop brain lesions
that we see on the
MRI of MS patients.
So as you can see,
rituximab is trimeric.
It's going to work
mainly somewhat by
antibody-dependent
cytotoxicity and then
complement-dependent
cytotoxicity. aqualizumab
is a fully humanized
one it has more
action in the antibody
dependent cytotoxicity
the other thing to
know is that over
time even though
these are still widely
used there's different
forms and you
can see that rituximab
is in fact trimeric
this is humanized,
this is fully human.
The newest one,
U-biltuximab, is
chimeric. But one thing
that's interesting and
very, very convenient
is that it's given
every six months.
So instead of the
patient having
to come for
monthly infusions,
this one carries
the benefit that the
patient does not
have to come every
month. They can come
every six months,
provided that they
can tolerate the
chimeric, the
antigenic possibility.
If they don't get
those side effects,
this will be a
good one for them.
Again, infusion
reactions can occur,
and we know that we
can manage this with
an antihistamine
like diphenhydramine.
You can get a
higher risk of
all infections,
respiratory,
all viral infections,
including hepatitis
B. So that's another
one that we may want
to check before we
start this medication.
Check their titers.
Do they need
another booster
of hepatitis B?
Maybe, maybe not.
But remember, these
vaccines should
be on board before
you start the
medication. And you
need to give a good
amount of time.
Usually they say
like a month or so.
Teriflunamide is a
metabolite of leflunamide.
This is used in
rheumatoid arthritis.
This drug inhibits
an enzyme known as
dihydroorotate dehydrogenase.
And that's going
to inhibit something
known as pyrimidines.
and pyrimidines and
purines they're involved
in synthesis of
DNA, RNA and there's
going to be more of
these when you do cancer
chemotherapy you're
going to see a bunch
and probably
the one that's
the biggest one
is methotrexate
but methotrexate
is a purine
it's going to affect
purines this
is pyrimidines
what's going to
happen for patients
that have MS, no
pyrimidines, no DNA and
RNA synthesis, no
cell proliferation.
Other things
pyrimidine block can do
is to stop phospholipids
from being made,
so you won't have
lipid messengers.
And it also will
inhibit protein
glycosylation. And
that's going to make it
that you're not
producing cell surface
molecules like
receptors of some sort.
But with MS,
this is our goal.
So if you're not
making RNA and
DNA, that means
you're not letting
your lymphocytes
live, so to speak.
So again, infections is
there, hepatotoxicity.
So you want to do a
liver function test.
And the other thing is
anything that
affects purines,
pyrimidines,
ultimately DNA, RNA,
nucleic acids, is
going to affect somebody
of childbearing age,
especially if they are
considering becoming
pregnant or are
pregnant. That's where
we start to get
teratogenic effects. So
remember, with
methotrexate and the lack
of purines, probably
the biggest adverse
effect that we see is
neural tube defects.
So the idea here
is, if you were to
give teraflunamide,
make sure that
you're doing a
pregnancy test in those
patients that
could be pregnant.
And then if they are
put on this medication,
they need to be on
oral contraception.
Incidentally, if
they finish this
course or they're
changed You still
have to continue the
oral contraception
for about 2 years
post-therapy
This drug has a
long half-life
On its own, it's 10 to
18 days So if you've
been taking it for a
while You're getting
some that's staying
in the system So
this is why you need
to make sure your
patient is very clear
that they have to
continue the oral
contraception and not elect
to become pregnant.
If they are, then
this is not the right
medication for them.
Mitoxantrone is for
secondary progressive MS.
Now the patient has
gotten to the point
that none of the other
drugs are working.
They're getting a
worsening of symptoms.
And mitoxantrone is an
intercalating agent.
It's another
antineoplastic. It's
known as an
anthracycline, and it's
doxorubicin-like.
Doxorubicin is in
the same family
of mitoxanthrone.
In the DNA, it's
going to cause breaks.
I tend to think of
interculating agents.
If I saw a DNA ladder
in front of me,
these drugs actually
break the stairs of
the ladder. So if you're
breaking the stairs,
you're not going to
be able to replicate.
And with this
medication, it's also
going to affect
membrane fluidity.
It's going to increase
oxygen species,
ROSs, not so much
in our body, but
in the cells that
we're targeting.
And ultimately, you're
suppressing B
and T cells.
You're decreasing B
cell function, and by
doing that, you're
not making antibodies.
And that would be
appropriate if we're
thinking about this
autoimmune disease.
Some of the adverse
effects are going to be
cardiovascular,
immunosuppression, we know,
some nausea and vomiting,
some loss of hair.
This drug and the group
are going to be used
for AML, prostate, and
breast cancer. So I
have the ruby circles
because if you ever
look at a bottle of
doxorubicin, it's red. The
way we and my pharmacy
colleagues remembered
this is that whenever
we saw doxorubicin,
we know that this
is one of the most
cardiotoxic
antineoplastics available.
When you're on
doxorubicin, you need to
do tests for your
heart before and after.
mitoxantrone is
probably not as high but
since it's still in the
class of interculating
agents it is still
recommended that you do
some type of baseline
cardiac function test
the issue is that those
ROSs that are targeting
the cells that we want
to kill can actually
affect the contractile
proteins in the
heart and over time that
can lead to something
called dilated
cardiomyopathy where the
patient will present
now with an increase in
heart rate. They're going
to have shortness of
breath, almost like a
presentation of CHF.
So doing the EKG,
doing frequent
echocardiograms is
going to be important.
Cladribine or cladribine
is a synthetic
deoxyadenosine purine
analog, but it's considered
to be an anti-pyrimidine.
So somewhat like
what you saw with the
terflunamide, okay?
This one is used for
hairy cell leukemia.
It's part of the anti
-metabolite class.
It's S-phase specific.
So S-phase means to
me, and you'll see it
later, it's the phase
where you're getting
DNA synthesis. So it
makes sense by affecting
pyrimidines or the
other half affect purines
like methotrexate.
You're not synthesizing
DNA and that's exactly
what we would want in
these B and T cells.
It seems to be that
cladribine has a greater
effect on the B cells
versus the T cells.
It also allows
for apoptosis
of the lymphocytes.
So what does that
mean? that perhaps
you're going to get
lymphopenia, which
means a lowering of
your white blood cells,
and you're going
to be at a greater
risk for infections.
So again, looking
at some of the titers
of these viruses,
whether it be varicella,
looking at
maybe hepatitis,
making sure that the
patient understands
they need to stay on top
of their vaccinations.
okay it's you know
towards you know the
middle of flu season
if these patients are
being treated for ms
they they should have
had their vaccines
in the fall they also
need to be mindful
where they're going if
they're living you know
in a house and they
have like young children
and children are
prone to picking up
infections they need to be
mindful of that okay
Okay, so in summary,
not all of the
drugs are here.
Remember, L-M2-zumab
is going to bind CD52.
By binding CD52,
you're going
to allow for cell lysis,
either by antibody
-dependent cytotoxicity
or complement
-dependent cytotoxicity.
Rituximab, aqualizumab,
afatumumab,
And then the newest
one that can be
given every six
months, they're going
to bind CD20. And by
doing that, you're
going to have an
effect now that
you're going to
decrease your B cells.
Dimethylfumarate makes
monomethylfumarate.
In the cell, inside the
nucleus, you're going
to get an increase
in the production of
glutathione, which helps
neutralize the ROSs.
Glutarimer,
okay? Now you're
increasing TH2,
which tends to be
anti-inflammatory.
And then, of course,
we have some of the
other drugs we
talked about, like
interferon. Interferon
is a cytokine itself.
By activating the
Janus kinase pathway
and allowing for
phosphorylation and activation
of signal transduction,
it's going
to prevent the migration
of those pathological
lymphocytes in the
CNS. It's going
to stop them at the
blood-brain barrier.
So as I mentioned,
one thing to know is
that patients with
MS are going to have
other symptoms. One
of them that I had
observed many times
in the pharmacy is
the need for them to
have adult diapers.
It's kind of hard
for patients to
accept that, but
it does happen. And
there are ways that
we can help with
that adverse effect.
So incontinence
means basically an
overactive bladder.
The way we manage
is by giving an
M3 blocker. So
remember, muscarinic.
M3 is on the
exocrine glands.
So this is why
when we give these
medications, we're
going to be prone
to dryness, dry
mouth, dry eyes,
constipation.
We're going to have
urinary retention, which
is actually the point
of giving these in
these patients. You want
them to not urinate,
okay?
They can get medriasis,
so if you have a
patient with glaucoma,
that can be a problem.
There may be some
selectivity issues, and
I'll explain that
in a moment, because
oxybutynin is non-selective,
and you'll probably
have more issues with
oxybutynin than the
other two that I have
highlighted in green,
okay?
Because even though
these are beneficial, we
need to be mindful of
the adverse effects.
The other thing about
muscarinic blockers,
and this is a very
important point that I
will highlight in some
of the other coming
lectures, is that through
the Beers criteria,
this is on the list
of drugs that we want
to avoid as much as
possible in the elderly.
Because if you're
giving a muscarinic
blocker, it's going to
cross the blood-brain
barrier. And what
tends to happen is that
these patients become
more delusional.
They have more cognition
problems. Okay, so
the idea here is
that we want to give
something that is less
adverse effects. We want
something that's going
to be selective for
the muscarinic receptors
in the bladder.
Because by doing that,
they're not affecting
the muscarinic receptors
everywhere else.
So there's a lower
incidence of those
adverse effects. And
remember, hard as a hair,
red as a beet, the
heart runs alone, dry
as a bone. That's how
you should remember
the adverse effects of
muscarinic blockade.
And where you are
binding in the bladder,
these M3 receptors,
you want to decrease
the tone of the
detrusor muscle there.
So tolterodyne and
darafenacin are the
newer drugs. these are
going to be a lot less
able to cause those
muscarinic block
effects than oxybutynin.
However, there's
still some reports
of these toxicities
happening. So you need
to be mindful of that.
The mechanism
is GQ and I'll
explain in a moment
what that means.
Another option is Botox.
Now, Botox, we
know, is used, you
know, cosmetically
for wrinkles
because it relaxes
muscle. So when you have
wrinkles and you're
injecting, the point
is that you're relaxing
the muscle there.
So now the area is
going to be more smooth.
So that's, you
know, the idea
for using it
as a cosmetic.
But Botox will
stop the release of
acetylcholine needed
for muscle contraction.
So,
thinking about what
happens is that you
need to get fusion of the
postsynaptic membrane,
basically, the
presynaptic. You need
to fuse it in order
to get, like in other
words, that spitting
out of acetylcholine.
And what makes
that possible is
SNARE proteins,
specifically SNAP25.
So, the idea here is
if we cleave SNAP25,
there's no fusion
of the vesicles.
So, no vesicle fusion,
no spitting out of
acetylcholine, and then
acetylcholine finds
calcium, and then
you get contraction.
So, Botox stops
that from happening.
Adverse effects
is paralysis,
okay? Okay,
so understand that
those people that
used to have these
Botox parties,
the idea here is if
you are injecting
this on your
own without the
expertise of a
healthcare professional,
there's been people that
can get really serious
problems. In worst
case scenario, you can
actually get paralysis
of your muscle. And
the one I'm thinking
about is a diaphragm.
You can actually go
into respiratory arrest.
so it's really no joke
when people are having
parties like this
they really should be
finding somebody who
has experience with it
other uses of of botox
is uh strabismus which
is known as almost like
a malalignment of the
eye and almost like
a cross eye that has
been shown to be effective
in those patients.
Blepharospasm is
rapid eye blinking.
And migraines and
cervical dystonia, it all
has to do, again, with
relaxing the muscles
in the area, whether
it be in the neck
or also in some of,
when we're thinking
about migraines, some
people can have problems
with some of their
muscles in the neck and
head region as well.
So muscarinic receptors
are GQ-mediated.
And I will say
that throughout the
year, every time I
give a lecture, I
do try to bring
in a review point.
So if I go over, that's
the point. I'm trying
to review as much as
I can. So see it as
a benefit for you.
And that's why I do a
question review after
each one of my lectures
to help you kind of
digest the key concepts.
But alpha-1,
V1, and M3 are
all GQ-mediated.
When the drug binds,
you're going to get
an increase in
protein lipase C, and
you're going to increase
IP3 and DAC. and
now you're going
to get now calcium
released and by the
action now of protein
kinase C you're going
to get contraction.
So the one I love
to talk about is
the alpha-1 receptors
because alpha
-1 receptors are
on the arterioles.
So if you're giving
an alpha-1 agonist
like phenylephrine
like you have
a cold and you're
trying to get your
nose to run, that's
a decongestion.
We know that phenylephrine
can raise blood
pressure, and it raises
blood pressure by this
mechanism. If you're
binding alpha-1 and
you're increasing calcium
in to the arterial,
that's going to cause
contraction. Contraction
is going to change
the blood flow, and
that's going to lead
to high blood pressure.
As we go on through
the semester and
next year, Some of
these concepts are
going to become
clearer, and you're
not going to need
to memorize as much.
The other problem
with MS is that the
patients are going to
have stiff muscles.
The way we manage is by
giving a muscle relaxer.
One drug is known as
tizanidine. This is
an agonist of the alpha
-2 receptor. If you
remember, clonidine
is an alpha-2 agonist,
and in the presynaptic
region, in the neurons,
it actually decreases
norepinephrine.
And by doing
that, clonidine
is very effective
at reducing
blood pressure
and heart rate.
This drug is going
to affect presynaptic
release of excitatory
neurotransmitters.
It's going to decrease
glutamate from
spinal neurons.
And that's going
to help relieve
some of that
enhanced muscle tone.
Because it's the
excitatory transmitters
that are really
driving up the
contraction of the
muscle in these patients.
Baclofen is a GABA-B
agonist. It has a G
-inhibitory mechanism.
This is going to be,
again, clear when I
do opioids because
opioids are also G
-inhibitory. So ultimately,
the drug will bind.
You're going to get
a decrease in adenyl
cyclase, a decrease
in cyclic AMP, a
decrease in intracellular
calcium, and a decrease
in transmitters.
What does this
mean for the
patients that have, say,
this problem
with muscle tone?
Well, again, going
back to decreasing
the release of excitatory
neurotransmitters
in the presynaptic
neurons.
Those excitatory
transmitters
are responsible
for the enhanced
muscle tone in
these patients.
Baclofen sometimes
can also be used in
patients that have
traumatic brain injury.
They too will have
enhanced muscle tone.
Adverse effects
of both of these
medications, you
have to be mindful
that they can cause
CNS depression.
Especially if they're
given with other
medications. So for
example, if you were using
baclofen and you were
using an opioid, the
problem would be that
you might have increased
CNS depression,
drowsiness, you might be
impaired if you are in
fact driving a vehicle.
so again i'm not going
to do this too in
depth because you will
have lectures but for
depression we could
give an ssri these
are the gold standards
for depression we have
snrides propion
which also block the
nicotinic receptors and
they can actually help
patients who are
trying to stop smoking.
Tricyclic
antidepressants, these
are going to
block the reuptake
of serotonin and
norepinephrine.
SSRIs are specific
for serotonin.
One thing about the
tricyclics is that
they're not widely
used anymore because
they have their own
adverse effects.
They could be dangerous
in an overdose.
But one thing
that they can do
is that they block
M3 receptors.
So, for example, if
you were depressed and
you were taking
amitriptyline, you would
have some relief from
your depression, but
you would also have
some relief from the
incontinence. But
again, some physicians
may not elect to use
tricyclics because,
as I mentioned, they
can be dangerous in an
overdose, and I'll
speak about it later.
And then those
people that have
trouble staying awake,
they would get a
stimulant, an
amphetamine, whether
it be methylphenidate
or modafinil.
And then as
mentioned, erectile
dysfunction
can be common.
And erectile
dysfunction drugs,
basically what
they're doing is
blocking
phosphodiesterase 5.
By doing that, you're
increasing cyclic
GMP, and that would
mean now you're getting
relaxation of smooth
muscle and improved
blood flow to the
area that you need it,
and that would relieve
the symptoms of ED,
and that is how drugs
like Viagra, which is
sildenafil, work. The
only issue is you have
to be mindful. If this
patient also has a
cardiac issue like
angina and they're given
a nitrate or a vasodilator,
this can actually
potentiate guanyl
cyclase and cyclic GMP.
And that would mean
that the patient is
getting extreme smooth
muscle relaxation.
their blood pressure
is going down so
dramatically that the
only way the body responds
is by baroreceptor
reflex mechanisms
you're going to raise
sympathetics and some
people can actually get
an mi and that's what
was happening early
on when viagra was
put to market they
didn't know they were not
warned of that
medication adverse effect
and some people actually
did die of an mi
So it's important
to make sure that we
don't give nitrates
with the drugs for ED,
the phosphodiesterase
5 inhibitors.
And then over
time, patients who
have MS may have
trouble walking.
Unfortunately,
some of them may
end up in using
a wheelchair or
sometimes in severe
cases, they're
bedridden. So we
have a drug here,
difamperdine, that blocks
potassium channels.
So what does this mean?
Well, in patients
that have
demyelination, the
action potential duration
is decreased
because of an
increase in potassium
channel opening.
so what happens is
that you as you can see
here if there's more
channels open the
potassium will leak out
and that has been shown
to have an effect
on the motor neurons
especially the action
potentials over there in
that area so the drug
actually comes in and
blocks the potassium
channels so you're not
getting leakage okay
and you're also by
doing that increasing
the action potential
nerve conduction and
if you can increase the
action potential in
the nerves that helps
with motor activity
such as walking okay so
that is one interesting
medication so I will
say that since this
is the first lecture
you have with me I
would advise you to go
through the question
review it usually does
take another 20 minutes
but most students in
the past and I've
been doing this for a
while have really found
that that extra 25
minutes does help kind
of cement the concepts
and it also makes you
see the question in a
u-world format so it
makes you practice for
your board exam so i
would advise you do
that with summary i would
say is to understand
that this is a disease
of demyelination
most of the therapies
will be immunological
okay and the target
is to somewhat
decrease pathological
lymphocytes t-cells b
-cells and then also
some of the drugs that
we use to manage the
symptoms whether it be
for incontinence with
m3 blockers or botox
or as mentioned for
patients that have
depression or erectile
dysfunction, okay?
There will be a full
lecture on antidepressants
as we go through
the semester, but
this is just somewhat
of an introduction.
Thank you for your
attention, everyone.
Please direct
any questions
to me, and I'll
see you soon.